el nuevo primer ministro de afganistán
fue uno de los primeros militantes del
movimiento talibán de hecho la autoridad
de mohamed hassan al jun deriva de su
vínculo con el difunto fundador del
grupo mulá omar de quien fue colaborador
y consejero fue viceministro de
exteriores cuando los talibanes llegaron
al poder en 1996 una posición que lo
convirtió en el principal interlocutor
del régimen con distintos países como
pakistán miembro del pueblo pastún
también fue gobernador de kandahar la
región meridional donde surgió el grupo
islamista a principios de los 90 a kun
está en la lista negra de la onu que lo
describe como uno de los comandantes
talibanes más eficaces tras la invasión
de la otan en 2001 y la caída del
régimen talibán pasó a la clandestinidad
pero continuó jugando un papel
importante en la organización
a kun contará con abdul ghaní baradar
como segundo en el nuevo gobierno
baradar fue cofundador del grupo
fundamentalista y es más conocido en la
escena pública en las conversaciones de
doha se encargó de negociar y firmar con
eeuu su retirada de afganistán